he's thinking okay the whole world saw
his meltdown against carlson he wants to
put those ghosts to rest for sure and he
looks sharp
i do miss the the man bun i must uh i
must admit but you must like the shirt i
love
of
it
it's a union jack yeah saying hello to
david and humanka yes very nice exactly
and uh okay first couple of moves it is
a queen's pawn opening and will we see
okay it is the catalan opening this was
the linchpin of magnus's opening
preparation for the world championship
match and they had an ongoing debate in
poland over the new year at the world
rapid championship they actually played
each other in a catalan opening as well
again
so this one a bit of history and uh
magnus has forced napoleon to think he's
looking off to the side there that's not
because he's looking at anything in
particular it's just he's trying to go
into recall mode
and uh
look at napoli actually deep in
concentration already trying to remember
what he had studied six months ago
or even more recently for the world
championship match this position i'm
pretty sure he's gone into detail on
but can he remember magnus will have
studied that this morning most likely so
it's going to be fresher in his mind and
the mind games have begun yeah how is
the magnus sort of feeling now and doing
now what is
on the back of his head after a uh you
know a bad loss against uh zepenko in
the last round yeah it's gonna be hard
for him but he is known as the king of
bouncing back nearly never see magnus
lose two games in a row sure one it
happens to everyone but magnus is great
and very strong psychologically he'll be
quite philosophical he'll say okay he
lost in the last round but he came up
against esopenko who was inspired who
just played a great game
life goes on it's still the prelim stage
and yeah he'll be trying to refocus
i have to say
one thing is that i recently spoke to
henrik carlson in an interview and he
gave a real insight into how magnus's
mentality is after a loss he is just
basically focused on the next target
he's like it's okay
move on to the next game the end yeah
let's say
it's easy to say but hard to do and
magnus does it very very well
and uh meanwhile the game has continued
there have been some exchanges so white
sacrificed the pawn a few moves ago he
hasn't regained that pawn yet now he
does have the opportunity to do that we
do see white's queen on the c file can
just step up two squares capture a black
pawn but that would allow black's knight
that has just moved the one highlighted
in orange there to swing across to the
left attack the white queen and attack
one of white's remaining pawns and i'm
trying to recall that if this is exactly
the course of any uh of magnus carlsen
against anishigiri from vikanze i think
it might be very similar i'm not sure if
it's exactly it is exactly it's the same
game yeah and that one magnus beat anish
geary yeah so magnus has fond memories
of this position but for sure napoli
actually will have gone and studied that
game i think all of the top players when
they see big new opening ideas from
their rivals they go away they study
those positions just in case it crops up
in their own games so magnus there
bringing his rook across and the pontiac
what's he going to do is he going to
move his knight is he going to push a
pawn nope he centralizes his bishop
instead and this is napomniaty's new
move because in the gary game
he actually picked up his a pawn and
moved it one square and instead he has
moved his bishop to over protect the
pawn that was under attack and the big
idea is that once white threatens to
push his pawn two squares forward the e
pawn that is
napoli actually just ignores it and just
moves his rook to the sea line getting
ready for the pawn break along that line
okay so has this been played before no
never no no no so this last move is new
over the last couple the last couple of
moves the bishop moving to the d5 square
is totally new and this idea
also incredibly
novel okay wow so fresh territory for
the two players it's going to be
interesting who continues to play
quickly up to this point they've both
actually gained time on the clock
they've got more time than they started
the game with
magnus slightly frowning as well maybe
he's confused by the pontiac's quick
moves and to be honest i am as well it
feels like black has lost a bit of time
especially with the black bishop black
bishop kind of zigzagged its way into
the game then it stepped forward to the
center now it stepped back he's provoked
white into gaining space in the center
with the white pawns look at those two
white central pawns
but those pawns might be a strength yes
they could be a target as well but
um magnus now retreating his knight he's
going after black's extra pawn on the c4
square you know what david i'm just
looking at the bar and i you know my
first thought was that this must be a
novel idea by napolita again provoking
the santa looking at the bar bar hates
it
i don't think this is in any shape or
form preparation this is just napoleon
perhaps being caught off guard and like
you say freestyling yup uh possibly
napoli actually freestyling or possibly
he just maybe mixed up his move orders
these types of positions often you know
the ideas you know you want to bring
your rook across you want to park your
bishop in the center but often if you
mix it up if you get it in the wrong
order the consequences might be dire and
right now black's pawn was doomed and
now he's offering it up for free or
seemingly so he has ideas in mind if
white captures this pawn that has just
advanced let's check out the
repercussions if white does go for the
most natural move and take this pawn um
just to show as well this position this
pawn is doomed the white knight is just
simply going to capture it next move
anyway and there's no way to defend it
so the pawn does push if white takes
then suddenly this pawn on the side
which
does look a bit irrelevant can't be
captured the white queen no longer
protecting it black would capture with
the bishop and
i still love white's position to be
honest white has these central pawns
white has the two bishops later on these
bishops are going to be fantastic along
these diagonals once the position opens
up but black is temporarily a pawn up so
maybe the most simple move or at least
the first move that comes to my mind is
not to capture this pawn is simply to
move the white knight back even further
not to its start square remember this
knight actually originated on the other
side of the board on the g1 square but
somehow it zigzagged its way to the
start square of its front of its other
knight and next move it's just gonna
capture on c3 and restore material
parity
and uh there we see the head-to-head
temporarily of the two players magnus
slightly ahead in last season's
champions chess tour but yeah if he
makes this knight retreat if he drops
his knight back and then captures the
spawn i have a feeling his head-to-head
score might increase against the pontiac
they have had a very interesting history
on the champions chess tour because i
remember their first time they played a
knockout match was all the way in the
beginning is skilling open and there it
was magnus carlsen who was victorious
and then they played each other in the
magnus carlton invitational and it was
napoleon who won who
ruined the party for magnus at his very
own tournament how rude but anyway i'll
just i joke um yeah i i have to say
david love your backward night move i
didn't actually see it i was just
considering the night jumping forward
but uh no
it makes total sense yeah there's some
stuff to calculate for example if the
white knight does drop back black's
knight in front of the black queen can
move out the way opening up the black
queen's vision against some pawns
but i think all of that does work out in
white's favor
the more i look at it the more i think
white is simply going to gain the pawn
back and white will have the long-term
advantage of the central pawns they're
controlling everything and the two white
bishops they're only going to gain in
power the longer the game goes on so i
think magnus has two good moves at least
maybe even more um just dropping the
knight back makes the most sense to me
he could even just capture this pawn
uh magnus of the last few years is more
kind of inclined to sacrifice pawns he's
been influenced by his work with daniel
dubois for example he'll just sacrifice
his pawns like like they're nothing
but okay this time magnus doesn't
capture the black pawn giving up his
sideboard he does go for the move i
suggested bringing his knight back
and the evaluation bar doesn't like it
initially but it does look pretty good
to me still and now black brought a
night out attacking white's pawn on the
side magnus reacting by pushing it
forward attacking the black knight and
the pony actually it's only one move he
has to jump forward with his knight and
attack the
bishop yep that would be the most
logical his knight is under fire so he
has to jump into white's half
you could potentially make an argument
for jumping it the other way maybe the
white knight the black knight to the
edge of the board to the a4 square but
that looks so
wrong it's so unnatural putting a knight
on the edge
and on a square where it will never get
out as well so trapping your own knight
but yeah i agree with you um just
instinct-wise bring the black knight in
towards the center to the c4 square
and uh at least try and trade off some
pieces
that's the key normally if you're
suffering in terms of space if your
opponent has the pawn center like white
does here just try and trade pieces off
because then you have more breathing
space you don't want too many pieces on
the board because then you'll just get
suffocated your pieces will fight for
the same squares and
um yeah long term that won't work out
for you so trading pieces is normally
the key there is a pressing question
though that magnus has to answer once
the black knight does jump into the c4
square attacking the bishop and that is
what's going to happen with the pawn in
the middle of the board that's on freeze
yeah are we going to give it up
or are we or is white going to do
something else maybe go on the counter
attack yeah that's a very good question
actually and just to show the ideas that
we've been uh discussing while napoli
has his first real think of the game um
we see that black's knight is under
attack from a pawn it has to run away i
mentioned this night move which looks so
unnatural putting it on the edge of the
board where it is trapped i don't think
we'll see that it's so uh kind of
counter-intuitive um instead the most
natural move mentioned by ivanka is to
bring the knight to this square and two
moves come into con
okay he's gone for the one we didn't
expect i just it was on my radar but i
just thought okay it will never happen
it's so ugly that move just to explain
this one if the knight had jumped
forward to this square magnus has
options he could save his bishop or he
uh for example bring it forward one
square just tempting the black queen to
come and capture a pawn but then he
would drop back take this pawn and once
the queen moves for example black would
now lose a piece after bishop takes
knight this knight is loose and will
drop off this looked very very strong
for magnus um i was going to say the
other option is just to capture this
pawn with the white queen take this pawn
and after this trade white is still
doing very very well due to these pawns
but napoli actually may be just seeing
this type of position and not liking it
he's gone for something even riskier
which could backfire this knight
attacked he's parked it on the edge of
the board and okay magnus doesn't try to
trap this knight he just takes a pawn
very simple play and now if the knights
come off white is better because of this
pawn center still rock solid and these
bishops are just fantastic napoli
actually has gone for a riskier approach
he's taken this pawn but
this looks so dangerous black's queen is
defending this knight on the edge of the
board the bishop is as well so black's
position not
well he's not losing anything yet but
it's hanging by a thread
for example if the white knight moves i
think white is doing well i'm trying to
work out the consequences of pushing
this pawn forward
partly attacking this knight partly
trying to get rid of this bishop which
is a defender of black's knight on this
side remember but suddenly it's becoming
a bit chaotic as we see by all the
arrows and magnus doesn't want the chaos
he just trades off on this square after
queen takes porn sorry um he just takes
this knight and after the black queen
recaptures
yeah suddenly i'm i was about to say i
think magnus is still doing pretty well
but suddenly he is a pawn down black has
a three versus two advantage here and
these doubled pawns are troubled pawns
for white uh these double pawns not
necessarily great either so
okay magnus may be just rushing and
missing an opportunity there just if we
backtrack
um the move i said the move i said is
complicated maybe magnus should have at
least invested
two or three minutes working out the
consequences there i think he would have
been doing quite well suddenly napoli
actually i mentioned he took a risk it's
worked out for him because after knight
takes night
the queens have left the board but black
is a porn up and white doesn't have the
best structure in the world ivanka
surprised
i'm very very surprised actually because
i i honestly thought that he would keep
the queens on in the game and try to use
the unchallenged power of his
dark-squared bishop yeah uh even if it
cost him two extra pawns you know that
bishop could have been a nuisance it's
not gonna yeah the dark square bishop
there and uh yeah especially on the long
diagonal and we saw some lines there
where it was a real menace towards the
black king and
just to trade off into an endgame
especially when white has such a poor
pawn structure
well
i'm going to it's the perfect
opportunity to share with you some more
lines and rhymes that uh our
twitterverse have come forward and it
goes
okay so uh we do have a move the bishop
has retreated onto the long diagonal
and oh no one of the double pawns are
going to disappear off the board so i
should say the rhymes very quickly
before they disappear okay so duke says
pawns in a column are uglier than gollum
and miguel rodriguez says okay white's
just tucked the bishop to a better
diagonal double pawns are ready to sorry
my double pawns are ready to mow your
lawn
clever yeah yes and uh female nurse says
double pawns easily haunt
double pawns easy horns yeah like
quickly easily horn yeah very nice so
very very nice great suggestions from
everyone yeah
yeah and then talking of double pawns
there's a real
really intriguing kind of situation now
with those white double pawns if you
look on the a line the corner file there
on the left white double pawns
there has been the opportunity for a few
moves now to trade one of them off for
one of the black pawns so getting rid of
your double pawns instead white has left
that tension he's maintaining the
tension now and magnus he's actually
offering up a second pawn he's one pawn
down but if black goes and captures that
white pawn on the edge of the board
suddenly black's pawns are doubled they
are the weak ones they've lost their
integrity they no longer defend each
other and black actually doesn't want to
get distracted
grabbing a pawn yes but also creating a
doubled pawn because if you look at
black's pawn chain they're far better on
the left there as
as a team they don't want to separate
and isolate each other and that's why
the tension persists and it's a bit of a
bluff now magnus is saying okay i'm just
going to leave that pawn for you to take
as a bit of temptation for the rest of
the game and uh yeah napoleon actually
is so far resisting that temptation
centralizing his rook and
actually the last few moves have
definitely gone in black's favor black
has started pushing on the port on the
side that where he has the pawn
advantage um black's knight maybe not
the best placed piece but white can't
challenge for the central file either
the defile because black's bishop on the
edge of the board is actually very well
placed on an outpost can't really be
kicked away
um yeah magnus he kind of raced to this
position he had a promising opening
everything was going in his favor and
there's suddenly one bad move and no
pontiac is on top wow that's how it
works at the top level if you're not
informed if you just if you're careless
for one moment your opponent will take
control he only has
four points after three games one win
one draw and juan los jianopomniacci six
points after winning two games losing
one game remember we are giving away
more points this season for those wins
and uh jana pognatchi he isn't shared
second we do have three players on seven
points
uh andreas penko one of them after two
wins and a draw so an exciting finish to
the day magnus carlsen he definitely
needs uh
he does not want to lose this game at
all he's going to be quite far behind
already yeah he needs to do something
differently um he's known as a slow
starter so he won't be panicking yet
often magnus loses the first game of the
day before kind of racking up a series
of wins in a row but if he loses this
one or if he doesn't win this one he's
going to start worrying slightly ahead
of tomorrow's action it is worrying
because it's three bad games you know
you have to go back to game two white
games today yeah exactly and this
by nature should have been quite a
straightforward day and i would have
expected him to finish on a plus score
but uh okay
can anything still happen though in this
game even if the bar is all the way over
the outside for sure all three results
are still possible and actually magnus
has set up a nasty trick he's got a big
big threat in the position to win one of
the black rooks but of course napoli
actually sees that uh maybe let's just
go into the position just to explain
what magnus is trying to do how he's
trying to justify his pawn deficit so
right now he's a pawn down but his last
move was to plant the bishop on this
square and if you look at the two
bishops this whoops sorry me and my
arrows again me and my mouth skills this
bishop cutting this diagonal this bishop
cutting the other diagonal black's rooks
are lacking squares so if black was
careless and just made a nothing move
then suddenly the white bishop would
jump forward and this is a pattern to
remember for everyone at home now this
rook lacks any escape squares it's hit
by the white bishop the white light
squared bishop and it's also cut uh from
retreating by the white dark squared
bishop that's why napoli actually
stepped back with the knight
sorry in this position he stepped back
with the knight attacking white's bishop
in the center there was no time to
attack the black rook the white bishop
had to retreat had to move and now it
was kicked back even further and this is
quite good strategy from janna pontiacci
he lacks a dark square bishop white is
the only one with a dark square bishop
therefore he occupies the dark squares
with pawns he blunts the effect of his
opponent's bishop with his own pawns and
it's looking good for napoli actually
plenty of good moves here for example he
could just bring his rook across
remember white cannot challenge for this
file because of the black bishop on the
edge of the board he can bring this rook
across oh whoops sorry not there he
could just bring it across one square he
can bring his knight back re-root the
black knight but he does go for this
move and
that's just a pawn up it's that simple
and that's why the evaluation bar is
going between zero between one for black
and uh it's just looking very very good
for napoli actually right now white
meanwhile bringing the rook across and
remember the other thing that we
mentioned the double pawns yes they
still exist but black doesn't want to
take himself because now these double
pawns will be troubled and this only
helps white open up the rook later on so
um yeah in the current position
winning chances for black cubanka do you
think they're quite high do you think
they're better than white's drawing
chances
um i think
50 i would say that white's
white's drawing chances are maybe 40
percent
and black's winning chances or maybe
50 55 i know the numbers are not my
forte
[Laughter]
but magnus you can see on his face he's
just not feeling
he's not in love with his position right
now
napoli actually okay just re-roots his
knight this is a great move you know
because i was thinking you know the
super power overnight is to
plonk itself in the center and if you
can do that and it's supported by its uh
pawns then and and if it can't be
attacked it's an outpost this is the
best type of knight so it made sense for
me to
for the pony actually to reroute the
knight it's heading to the d4 square
yeah the knight can use both colour
complexes to jump in and it's going to
jump into the center magnus really
unhappy with his position i mean it's
bad understandably though he's
okay he decides rather than sit
passively and wait for black to continue
improving the position
he's trying to initiate or at least
trying to open up some lines he's
offering a pawn trade here to be honest
black can probably just ignore that but
uh black can fortify his pawn center he
can push his own pawn to defend the
black central pawn even if black trades
off here
i think napolita is doing very well
personally i wouldn't want to trade
these set of pawns because then white's
bishops might come to life again
but
yeah either way magnus i do like his
last move just from a kind of
psychological standpoint he's showing
that it's not going to be one-way
traffic he does have some active ideas
of his own and i think that's just a
good tip for everyone at home
if you're struggling and you're bound to
be struggling at some point in some
games then just activate your own pieces
at least create your own ideas and scare
your opponent if possible pony actually
now knows it's not going to be
completely one-way traffic at least
all right well maybe a little bit of
trouble for magnus carlsen in this game
so far bars in most of the games are you
know towards the middle but i'm noticing
levonironian had so far had a great day
i think the bar is slightly over to hans
niman's side in that game so that could
be interesting and also
vincent kymer another 17 year old who
seems to be doing great in game four
against the great chocolate mom and
diario so again
we're probably going to have some
fantastic
fighting chess and a great result anish
geary the bar also going up in his game
against alexandra costano
so
let's see what kind of results we have
in round four today it's interesting you
say that because we actually have a
tweet from tariya svensson who says
the stats are showing that the players
are fighting
i love it 17.
24 games have been decisive in the first
three rounds whoa
yeah it will be fascinating to compare
that to the prelim stage of some of the
tournaments last last season on the tour
i know compared to classical tournaments
classical chess over the board i think
the draw rate is uh normally in excess
of 60 percent so
um yeah this these numbers are great
these numbers are promising yeah four
season ahead
kudos to the players for giving us
fighting chess that is what we love jana
pomnyacci is he feeling confident in
this game now or is it uh you know still
a long way to go for him as well i i
think
with these last two moves that have
appeared on the board i have suspicion
that things are not so clear cut anymore
because
yes
both rooks are being under attacked and
uh
i know the position's suddenly very wild
and open and black's past porn majority
on the left
is going to take a while to get
mobilized
yeah the evaluation bar definitely
a bit confused about what is happening
here i must admit i'm slightly surprised
black had three or four ways i felt to
keep control maybe not necessarily
pushing forward with the advantage or
trying to increase it but just
maintaining the extra pawn keeping
control of all squares keeping
especially the diagonals blocked for the
white bishops but
suddenly okay magnus laughing meanwhile
i wonder what that's about but yeah
suddenly things have opened up as you
mentioned ivanka and white has won a
pawn back
it's still double trouble and it's
double set of double pawns right now for
white in the center and on the side of
the board so that's not ideal for white
but
yeah for sure magnus will be slightly
more optimistic than he was three or
four moves ago
and napoli actually there's one thing as
well i will mention against magnus in
the world championship match his
technique in better positions wasn't
necessarily flawless
and
we will see whether he's still able to
create something here with black
meanwhile white rook was attacked and it
has moved so black's bishop now has to
decide does it go back and try and
capture a pawn
which direction does it retreat in i'm
trying to work out the consequences
there i think maybe magnus is going to
escape this game now
um yeah yeah pontiac just
it feels like both players have rushed
slightly in critical moments white
earlier rushing when he had an advantage
and suddenly on the defensive side black
having that advantage did rush and now
it's disappeared slightly
it was also due to the counter-attack as
well earlier black brought his bishop
down attacking the white rook maybe he
just forgot the wiki counter-attack by
capturing a pawn attacking the
blackbrook
sometimes
the players
need to just take an extra few seconds
to work out the consequences there
meanwhile napoleon actually rushing back
to the board doesn't take a few seconds
he does capture
that central pawn so black again on pawn
up but there are tactics in the position
suddenly white's bishop if it does move
might allow an attack against the black
bishop in the center from white's rook
at the bottom of the board there you've
got to be careful how you do it white's
bishop as well on the sixth rank is kind
of ex it's got x-ray vision
by the black rook it is kind of
indirectly attacked
yeah
so much going on there is definitely a
lot going on and i'm also looking at
those beautiful pawns on the on the left
you know nice chain but can be
destabilized actually by those double
pawns
so it's not easy at all
no um i think now is the time though for
magnus he needs something over the next
three or four moves to justify being a
pawn down otherwise i think once the
black knight joins the action it's gonna
be trouble for white so
um yeah the black knight just needs
maybe two moves to get into the game so
magnus has this small window of
opportunity to create something create
some threats and probably actually looks
pretty happy though
knowing him he probably thinks he's
winning but but uh how is the knight
going to get mobilized because you know
it's not too many squares for it to jump
to so i mean if it jumps in front of its
rook well there's a little bit awkward
maybe some pinning going on there and if
it jumps sorry yeah for example just to
show your idea yeah there would be a pin
on this line uh carry on your anchor and
if the knight did jump to the sixth row
well then they would disrupt the
coordination of the rook along the sixth
row
so yeah maybe not an ideal square for
black right now
magnus instead of just playing a useless
move just i was just demonstrating here
what black's plans are he did improve
his rook i should also mention some
viewers at home were probably wondering
why the bishop can't jump out of the way
taking upon attacking this black bishop
but after the pawn recaptures yes you
get the black bishop but suddenly the
rook has opened up against the white
bishop and at the very end black would
emerge with an extra knight so that is
why magnus couldn't go for that tactic
it doesn't quite work that's why we also
always look one move extra one move
further in case we've missed anything he
brings his rook across one square and i
think this has an idea of lining up
against this vulnerable f7 pawn actually
this f7 pawn we say at the start of
chess when we teach beginners that's the
most vulnerable pawn it's only defended
by a king and while the tactics have
started the black rook brought itself up
one square defending this opponent
magnus
has he just thrown away a pawn for free
or is there a sneaky idea behind this
this is very very clever if you tap if
you take the pawn with the rook then
okay the white bishop will sneak its way
to the eighth row and that would not be
a good news for napomiasi skewer yep
both black rooks and if you take with
the pawn if you take with the pawn i
guess the idea is now you've severed the
connection on the sixth rank uh for
blacks rooks and now you could finally
break the tension over here trade these
set of pawns and at the very end white's
rook would leap into the game black is
still a pawn up but suddenly there are
huge threats for example of pinning the
black knight on this rank this pawn
under fire suddenly everything's opening
up as you notice all the diagonals are
starting to open and therefore this will
favor the bishops suddenly i think white
is doing very very well so magnus
super sharp spotting that this would not
even be on my radar i must admit you're
pushing a pawn forward to a square where
it can be captured in three different
ways but all of the ways have their
downsides so pawn forward it has to be
captured
i'm starting to think maybe the best is
to capture with this rook ivanka just
give up some material and after the
bishop does come forward with this
skewer you've got to protect your
your pride and glory and just move the
rook to the sixth row and after a trade
here you still protect your pawns
actually
maybe it's easier for white to play
because long term you will be able
whoops sorry me and my arrows again long
term you will be able to start targeting
some of these black pawns on the queen
side
but either way um napoli actually has a
huge decision to make
does he give up material or does he
allow white to break through
on with his pawns on this flank you know
i think
that pawn move is maybe a game changer
and i i have a suspicion that it's so
shocking that it will be napogniachi
who might lose the threat and even throw
away the game
yeah game change is a great phrase for
it it just changes the momentum
completely black was in control covered
all the squares black probably thought
he had this square covered in every way
imaginable it's literally protected
three times but magnus says no this
ruins the coordination behind your
pieces and
yeah no matter which way you capture now
there's going to be a huge problem so
okay maybe you just take this way and
then
i don't know just leave it push a pawn
and hope that you're okay here in a
situation like this black would have a
knight and two pawns for the white rook
which is roughly level material at least
then maybe you could try and jump in
with the black knight as well
this is the best i can see right now but
it does take guts and courage to give up
some material after this pawn push to
give up one of the black rooks for a
white bishop
yeah yeah i think he has to do it and
whilst we're waiting for napoli actually
to react this really shocking move i
have to one final
rhyme and uh this is from air things our
sponsor tournament this is pawns when
stacked
get attacked wow
lovely one well you know when you have
great air quality you will come up with
great rhymes like that yeah exactly just
has to happen
air things uh
also monitoring the air quality for our
players obviously you need great air
quality to play great chess and well
maybe magnus's air quality is improving
right now yep his position on the board
is definitely improving and uh we saw he
actually had decent levels of co2 decent
uh decent stats there it was very warm i
couldn't play in such warm temperatures
like magnus does 26 degrees as we see on
the screen
but either way his position has improved
and he's picking up the speed so
normally we see players
you know their level does deteriorate
over the course of the day
magnus that did happen in the last round
struggling there but he's picking things
up now and uh
suddenly we did actually see the knight
capture that white pawn in the center so
black's pawns on the left side have just
been eliminated uh white is still a pawn
down though
so white is the one fighting for the
draw despite the fact things are much
better for him now than they were just a
few moves ago and uh meanwhile black is
pushing harry the hbo trying to break
through to the white king yeah and uh
there is a big problem in the air for
magnus which is how is he going to
defend
his king and the first threat is pawn
takes pawn rook takes pawn winning and
uh
if you're careless and just play
passively then the black knight was
actually threatening to come to the g5
square and maybe even deliver checkmate
so yeah let's show that on the board
ivanka because that's a very pretty uh
checkmate um white has actually just
eliminated that black knight but if he
hadn't for example
if he just dropped back with the bishop
defending this pawn this is the idea you
mentioned right it looks like this black
knight is pinned along this line but
nope it can jump forward and
after the rook takes rook this would be
a really stylish checkmate do you know
the name of this checkmate i don't like
it it's called the suffocation mate
suffocation mate the knight checking the
king but uh let's capture up with the
moves white decided that was too
dangerous eliminating the black knight
and after the pawn captured white gave a
check and is white going to be sneaking
out and try and threaten checkmate team
up his rooks at the top of the board and
try and sneak behind the black king and
trap it well he's threatening it in a
different way
in a different uh using a different
angle he's brought his rook up attacking
the bishop and attacking his pawn let's
go back to the players because the moves
are coming thick and fast black gave a
check and now black pinned the white
rook as we see there on the f line
white's rook can no longer move and
magnus still frowning he knows he still
has work to do to save this game
opposite color bishops though if all of
the rooks disappear it's going to be a
draw so magnus he's still a pawn down
but he does have this saving grace of
trying to trade off all the rooks
if he can okay so is that then jana
pogbach's main objective now to just
keep them on the board you'll want to
keep one set of rooks okay he doesn't
need both of them not necessarily i
think now he's offered a trade of one
set of rooks that's just to secure the
black king he knew the black king was
about to come under fire from the two
white rooks so trading one is fine
and okay magnus goes and grabs a pawn
i'm not sure about that grab not sure i
really i'm not sure because it gives
what black the opportunity to actually
advance harry one more square and
suddenly white's pawn on h2 is a huge
liability that falls it's going to be
trouble actually that's a great move
your anchor pushing that black pawn
forward one square fixing a weakness
actually that black pawn the h pawn if
it does move forward it's two squares
away from promotion it promotes on a
light square supported by black's bishop
in the middle
the more i look at this more i think
white is in for some real suffering if
that happens
um i'm also wondering whether you can
give a check at some point or whether
you can bring the yeah black rook across
but
nopony actually was shaking his head
which makes me think
maybe he's doubting his winning chances
here
even though there's still a lot of life
left in this position
and the evaluation bar backs up
your conclusion that black is doing very
well
look at magnus carlsen
is he laughing yeah
is he laughing at his own moves his own
play is he laughing
oh it's intense as well
any time we question him about it though
he always seems to conveniently forget
his reason for laughing
should we keep asking though
why not
maybe one day he's gonna answer us maybe
one day he's gonna tell us the joke he
is thinking about yeah i wouldn't be
laughing about this position in ivanka i
would be terrified that i was still in
trouble
i i don't think i would be laughing
especially in this time control but then
on the other hand
i have actively tried to do this
technique of laughing when i'm in a bad
position
and it's worked
to get inside your opponent's mind well
kind of like you kind of relax and
you're like well you know made a mess of
this
not my proudest moment what's gonna
happen
let's see if i can save this
yeah okay so will magnus save this so if
a set of rooks have come off the board
i'm expecting yan now to bring his rook
actually to the corner um the black rook
to target that white h-pawn once that
falls black still has this huge
trump card up his sleeve
and
i think white's still in a bit of
trouble there magnus he's refocused but
napoli actually doesn't look happy
why is he shaking his head he's still
got a great position
and no risk as well any time napoli
actually wants he can probably swap off
the rooks and just guide the game
towards a draw so no risk he can play on
here
yeah i don't know i don't really see
anything because um
it does look on a superficial level that
maybe white has everything covered
but you know once the black pawn gets to
h3 you know there's going to be a little
bit of a barricade barrier to white's
defense along the second row but not
this way actually i'm not happy with the
way that napomiacci's done this yeah it
feels like he's missed the moment and uh
yeah suddenly the white rook has got
back to its kind of a great defensive
square
covering the second rank that's where
black's rook should be
trying to target those white pawns on
the second rank
um so yeah white's rook now
just locking down some defense and
yeah it feels like napoli actually may
be missing his moment that being said
the black king will start to enter the
position black is still the one
who should have the winning chances i
think white is still fighting for the
draw and there we go the black king does
finally remember to join the party
and it's not actually going to be easy
to track its entry into the right
position that black king is going to
continue marching white now is banking a
lot on his past pawn the one he's just
pushed
but unfortunately it's not going to get
so far because you can even get to the
seventh row but it's not moving
not moving to the promotion square at
all exactly it's going to be covered by
black's bishop in the center
and now we go with some checks
slightly mysterious checks black's rook
is kind of taking the long way round it
could have i mean it was on the first
rank just a few moves ago
slightly surprising that black rook is
going after white's pawn over there that
pass pawn on the left
but it's slow where will white put the
king
magnus still needs to be highly accurate
to save this game which way would you go
ivanka three squares okay he went to the
center yeah i'm tempted to go to the
center as well you know and actually
maybe even bit further
to try to support this
pawn on the left but maybe you can't
keep that pawn black rook is now
attacking um that white pawn
how do you maintain it maybe you don't
and that pawn does ha
it has just dropped off if the white
rook went to protect that pawn we should
mention then the white rook would have
evacuated the second rank and black's
rook would have pounced with some deadly
checks so uh black's gone a porn up
that's actually been a pawn up for most
of the game
and uh he's upon up again and the rooks
are still on the board that is the key
so white will not be safe until he's
able to trade a set of rooks and this is
a very sneaky move from magnus so he's
threatening to slide the rook to g1
square give a check and actually grab
the pawn on g7
yup so black giving a check himself will
white block that check if white's king
moves out the way then the black rook
will swing the whole way across the
board and capture
oh actually maybe it can't uh maybe
there's a trick in the position i was
about to suggest an awful blunder
maybe we can show this on the board
because there is one trick right now
the safest move is to block the second
rank block this rook trade and the rook
is protected by its bishop okay he does
go for this i was going to say he can
maybe just move his king forward because
after rook takes pawn which i wanted to
suggest suddenly pawn forward check and
there's a discovered attack against the
black rook once black replies to that
check the rook would fall and white
would be the one winning so okay instead
magnus not setting that trap he blocked
with his rook protected by the bishop
rook trades would lead to a draw so
black retreated and now white again
going back this way round as ivanka
mentioned to try and
capture this black pawn on the dark
square there was a sneaky
trick in the position that magnus set
and just if we can go back one tiny move
and if the rook had gone to the first
row
the black crook can go to the seventh an
attack and again use the discovered
attack the white rook could have yep
jumped forward and a discovered attack
against blackstroke also attacking this
pawn so both sides are actually setting
some small tricks here and there let's
catch up with the current position
black's king now about to enter can it
sneak forward or is there no time maybe
white needs to stop this advance of the
black king bring the white rook across
not fear ghosts of a discover check here
he's done it because if the black bishop
moves with the discover check as it has
done this is a check the white king just
moves out the way and still awkward for
white look at this rook blocked in now
by black's bishop but
suddenly this white pawn is pretty safe
it's going to be
nigh on it impossible to actually attack
this pawn white is going to hold
everything on the dark squares
and okay wow risky move by white i would
be scared of rook takes bishop now
and then bring the king in but maybe
it's all under control
let's go back to the players we're going
to see a maneuvering stage
white if he wants to hold this game if
magnus wants to hold the draw you're
still going to have to defend for a long
long time
57 moves do you think we'll see a
hundred no i don't think i i think
napolmashi has maybe
not played it so accurately because
magnus actually has the idea of
recentralizing the bishop to the e5
square and the rook actually coming to
the seventh row you can even give up
the pawn because the black king is so
awkwardly placed uh possibly possibly
yeah so maybe we'll see that move now by
white that would require some
calculation black's pawn may be pushing
forward
yeah maybe some checks from the black
rook still a lot to consider i
personally i'm going to say it now i
think this move is going to go over this
game is going to go over 100 moves
or at least it would if i was playing
well we know these two can play long
games as well longest game in world
championship history game six in dubai
yeah what was it hundred and thirty
eight 130 something moves
yeah seven hours
remember that yeah
i mean that was a long day we were here
for nine hours in the studio yeah
what a crazy day oh up until the time
control
with 40 moves so dramatic and then
black was better than white was better
than black was then it was just a draw
for the next 50 moves and then magnus
finally wore down his opponent
okay the rook does come across
okay but this does allow
black to give a check with the rook yeah
and uh allow the black king to enter
yeah so will we see napolitani once he
returns give a check with the black rook
the alternative would be to once again
block the white rook by bringing the
black bishop down in front of it
so
yeah black now can just kind of maneuver
kind of go round and round in circles
hoping for a mistake
and as the clock stick down the more
likely it will become that magnus does
eventually slip up we should mention
that there is a big trap in the position
huge danger threat there is a threat and
it's a checkmating threat my favorite
thing and if uh magnus is uh sorry
napoleash is really careless and maybe
just picks up the pawn moves at one
square
yeah the rook will come to give a deadly
check on the g5 square and that would be
checkmate so
yeah definitely something that family
actually won't fall for so that's why he
gives a check
and the magnus steps his king back
so hitting the white king there the king
had to retreat has it retreated the
white way uh the right way
that is the question the white king
this pawn is maybe gonna drop off that's
the problem for napoli actually the more
paws that disappear the closer white
will get to the draw
there's no real way to save it
you can save it by putting the bishop
back
to the blockading square okay but then i
guess the bishop will just capture this
pawn potentially and then it will be a
trade it will be a trade and black does
have one plus pawn so still still some
glimmer of hope the probably actually
meanwhile chose a different option um in
this position he just pushed it forward
one square and now magnus does have the
option if he wants of giving a check but
i don't think black would actually
capture this pawn
maybe he could but maybe he'll just
march into the position with his king
actually okay we'll find out now find
out he does march in with his king and
now the white bishop is attacked the
white pawn is attacked where is the
bishop going to go you've got to be
really careful if you go to the center
now i just have a feeling that things
are going to start to crumble black's
rook will come and try and target this
vital pawn it's actually all about this
guy right
if this pawn falls black will win black
has this pawn two squares away so
magnus what is he gonna do with this
bishop
aside from dropping it all the way back
i mean this is ugly but is it necessary
maybe to just guard this porn long term
i mean could he have any dirty tricks up
his sleeve so for instance if he puts
his bishop in the middle of the board
um
like rooks say it steps away steps
across
and now i need something clever because
my idea is actually once the black rook
attacks and grabs that pawn then maybe
there might be some pawn pushes okay so
you want to push this pawn out the way
eventually and it looks like magnus has
the same idea but how do you
orchestrate it so that it works yeah
let's go back to the players though
because i think this move rook across
and rook down targeting this pawn is
going to be very strong for black and
the evaluation bar has shot up in
black's favor so
this is what we're talking about
objectively this end game might be a
draw but it requires such precision and
it's nearly impossible in a rapid game
with two minutes on your clock to find
the best moves every time clocks are
ticking look at that uh janna pogniacci
down to three minutes on the clock
dingle wren and liam lee have finished
their game dingler and winning that one
so ding he is now on top of the table
with
10 points three wins today for dingley
ran amazing yeah and he's earned his
night of sleep it's what is it nearly 5
am now in china
it's so late
impressive stuff he has had quite an
easy start to the tournament with uh a
few of the lower rated players in the
tournament but nevertheless fantastic
first day for dangler uh currently on
top of the table i don't think anyone
can esipenko could if ezipenko wins this
game he can catch up with him
see if that happens all right but in
this one magnus carlsen could be about
to uh
uh go on another loss
yup he needs to find something really
clever here to save this game so black
didn't use the route that i was
advocating he didn't go to the edge of
the board instead he's trying to sneak
across and deliver a check to the white
king so that's why the white king has
stopped the black rook coming down
um okay no probably actually surprised
by that one that looks like a very
clever move but the white king might be
in some danger there are some
checkmating ideas against it
if you imagine the black king coming
down one square the black bishop moving
to the side the black rook is ready and
primed to deliver some checks or
checkmates yeah once the black king
steps forward the white king is in a
cage like you say and even trading off
rooks is not necessarily going to save
him because suddenly there's a past born
on the h line yeah so
dangerous dangerous stuff for magnus
wow i'm amazed he's looking so calm
magnus just because it's such a scary
position to deal with and it's such a
one-sided position if you defend
perfectly you get a draw but on every
move there are so many pitfalls one slip
and you're just going to be checkmated
all blacks h pawn is going to promote to
a new queen
so much can go wrong okay so napoleon is
actually setting the trap so black's
next move if magnus is careless is to
step forward with the black king one
square
and
has he just allowed it okay i think he's
got
i think he's got a defense in mind and
that is simply to bring the white rook
the whole way back to the first rank um
to stop any potential checks that's why
napoli actually flicked in the check i
agree with you ivanka i would have
probably gone for that anyway as black
um just creating some checkmate ideas
now white's king is out of the cage out
of the box the white king's run to
safety but
is that h pawn doomed black's rook is
ready to go across two squares and
capture
how do you save it it's not easy
white now has to hope for a miracle okay
that pawn has disappeared and
okay i think magnus running out of ideas
here i'm surprised the evaluation bar is
only saying plus two for black because
that black pawn is so close to promotion
that is
too squares yeah now if the rook's come
off it's definitely not a draw anymore
there's no safety net there because
black's porn is destined to become a
queen and the promise doing something
very smart he's using his king to
blockade the motion the range of white's
bishop and uh
magnus is smiling yeah but i mean that
looked like an ironic smile and has he
just resigned i think he's just resigned
black was about to make a new queen that
black pawn is going to cost white the
rook maybe magnus missed something i'm
not sure what it was though because that
was very logical played by black and
there we go the world champion loses for
a second game in a row wow kudos too
yana pomniacci though i mean obviously
it's not
the big revenge after uh losing the
world championship match but a great
game by him yep a great game um maybe it
wasn't as smooth as he would have liked
but he was always slightly better after
the opening at least he always had a
small advantage white was always on the
back foot and
yeah the russian taking the points